قصف جديد وغاره جديده نفذ الطارات
الاحتلال الحربيه على هذا المنزل لعائله
عرام في معسكر خان يونس هذا القصف ادى الى
وقوع عدد من الاصابات خاصه من جوار هذا
المنزل حيث هذا المنزل مخلى كما علمنا من
شهود الاعيان وجيران هذا المنزل دار
مسكونه عاديه دار مسكونه هذه فيها اطفال
فيها نساء عزل يعني مش عارف كيف اسرايل هذ
جرائم حرب
هذه اباده جماعيه شوف هذه جنوب افريقيا
تحقق بدها تحقيق يعني كل شي واضح كل شي
مبين ايش اللي بصير هذا احنا عننا اباده
جماعيه هي اللي
بنفهم الاصابات تم نقلها الى مستشفى ناصر
من جوار هذا المنزل الذي تم تدميره اضافه
الى اضرار بالغه لحقت بالمنازل المجاوره
بعد عمليه تدمير واسعه قامت بها احتلال
الحربيه لهذا المنزل المواطنون في هذه
اللحظات يحاولون قدر الاستطاعه جلب بعض
المقتنيات او استخراج بعض المقتنيات بعد
عمليه التدمير التي حصلت لهذا المنزل بعد
ان تم نقل اصابات من داخل هذا المنزل
وجوار هذا المنزل في صفوف المواطنين هذه
الصوره مع كل عمليه تدمير تقوم بها طائرات
الاحتلال لمنازل مواطنين مدنيين مع
استمرار هذه الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع
غزه هذه الصوره في كل منطقه وفي كل مشهد
والمشاهد العدوان الاسرائيلي في قطاع غزه
لقناه الجزيره اسماعيل ابو عمر خان يونس